[Musique]
marie au premier regard on est libre de
faire ce qu'on a envie de faire
voilà s'il y en a qui veulent consommer
le mariage la première nuit ils le font
s'ils veulent pas du tout consommer le
mariage il le veut la prod mais
absolument pas responsables de ce qui se
passe quand on off cécile alain partent
en corse pour leur voyage de noces et la
ccil vous vous libérer un peu
complètement un ça va mieux vous
commencez à être beaucoup plus tactile
alors assez pour la petite île valeur
additionnelle des buttes moi j'appelle
ma fille ça mon bébé non je ne put
jamais tu attends je te bute avoir au
téléphone je regarde plus jamais la télé
et me raccroche au nez
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à nice ça ça
vous plaît pas non mais ça ça me dérange
c'est mal is an noncé je ne sais pas je
ne s'amuse m je vois pas en quoi c'est
quelqu'un quoi en plus maintenant que
c'est un inconnu en fait on ne peut pas
être comme ça donc non alors donc là
c'est son mari s'épanouissent et a
menacé
vous étiez énervé quand vous avez vu ça
oui ça m'a énervé des rejets la plus
crue jouera cochonné point fr sans doute
mais en fait c'est qui la mère et la
fille c'est la fille qui met des coups
de pression est là l'image elle à
l'image de maman voilà sa maman ne doit
bien sûr est énorme alors on a ça fait
des années que je suis que maman et
c'est vrai que l'allemagne a jamais vu
embrasser un homme et on a mis ça vous
pensez que votre maman l'embrasserai
plus jamais aucun homme bassil après
celle de la demande 3 millions de
personnes ça me gêne un peu quand même
ces gens se montrent plus les audiences
qui on voit votre maman
il ya énormément de personnes de 40 ans
qui sont seules avec des enfants vous
interdisent de se reconstruire en tant
que femme je reçois énormément de
messages là dessus donc elle même m'a
regardé bernard si je peux laisser jeu
si je peux envoyer un message pour ces
femmes-là qui elles sont quand je dis
sacrifier moi je dis que c'est vraiment
un sacrifice j'ai fait mon rôle de maman
mais plus plus plus plus plus on a eu un
parcours très très très difficile avec
anissa grâce à dieu ça se passe beaucoup
mieux mais si je peux envoyer un message
à toutes ces personnes qui espèrent
rencontrer un jour quelqu'un me guy
voilà qui ont eu 2 qui y avoir une
deuxième chance et être voilà ne pas
qu'être maman je suis là là je suis là
pour ça ce soit